je vous en prie installez-vous merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité ce matin on
est ravi de vous recevoir sur ce plateau
vous êtes avocat pénaliste président
d'honneur de la Ligue des droits de
l'homme et évidemment on a envie d'avoir
votre regard sur ce qui se passe en ce
moment dans le pays troisième et demi de
violence dans plusieurs villes du pays
en de Marseille à Roubaix Brest Rouen
Tourcoing en passant évidemment par la
région francilienne et par Nanterre
après la mort de ce jeune homme tué par
un tiers de policiers est-ce que pour
vous c'est violence sont inévitables
ces violences
inévitables on ne sait jamais mais ce
qui est certain c'est que lorsque mardi
matin on a appris qu'un jeune homme
avait été tué la suite d'un refus
d'obtempérer on s'est trouvé dans une
situation classique et je me disais
qu'une nouvelle fois nous avions être
obligé d'essayer de déceler dans les
propos qui étaient tenus les
informations que nous avions et les
informations que nous avions c'était
comme d'habitude le policier et s'était
senti menacé il avait craint pour sa vie
etc et puis il y a eu alors je sais pas
ce qu'il y avait mais enfin c'était le
bruit qui en coupait plus que le bruit
ces informations
et puis il y a eu brusquement la sortie
de cette vidéo et là ça a été un choc
terrible d'un choc pour nous il est vrai
que ce ce gamin ce jeune homme tout
jeune homme tué à Abou portant à bout
portant c'est-à-dire que là sur le côté
d'une voiture c'était un support des
images sont insupportables et je connais
malheureusement nous savons bien d'ici
l'extrême tension qu'il y a actuellement
dans un certain nombre de quartiers et
ce quartier il y a des gens les jeunes
tout le problème des banlieues comme on
dit entre guillemets et nous savions et
nous savions qui n'éluctablement il y
avait y avoir une une révolte ceux qui
ont vu récemment le film Les Misérables
là qui montre justement ça dans une
banlieue en grande partie mais bon on
avait tous le souvenir bien entendu de
de des événements de 2005 de ces gosses
qui avaient été brûlés et et ça moi j'ai
dit c'est ça va ça va arriver et ben
malheureusement c'est arrivé et la
situation de révolte est une situation
qui est très intéressante parce que le
gouvernement se trouve non pas en face
d'un groupe de quelque chose qui est
organisé et un peu comme c'était le cas
des gilets jaunes mais la situation est
différente il se trouve en face d'une
immense manifestation spontanée qui a
lieu partout c'est-à-dire que c'est
toute une population qui se révolte qui
se sent en situation de fraternité avec
cet enfant
tué et avec sa mère et cette espèce de
solidarité générale provoque
effectivement des mouvements or vous
savez comme
c'est une solidarité générale de la
genèse de la jeunesse des quartiers où
ça va au-delà de la jeunesse et ça va au
delà des quartiers
général de la joueuse des quartiers qui
en plus se trouve en face d'une opinion
publique qui est quand même
bouleversé par la mort de saint
heureusement heureusement heureusement
que
la population est bouleversée par la
mort de cet enfant alors à partir de ce
moment-là il y a des réactions
différentes mais il est évident que la
révolte générale de la jeunesse était
quasiment une situation inéluctable et
vous savez la révolte surtout la révolte
dans des conditions pareilles des gens
qui ont été si longtemps secouer
évidemment la révolte se nourrit
elle-même elle se développe c'est comme
un feu ça s'embrasse et je suis malgré
tous les efforts malgré les 40000
policiers etc la révolte a été la
révolte et la la et toutes les scènes
qui ont pu avoir aujourd'hui par une une
fracture entre la police et cette
jeunesse écartée voir une haine de la
police dans cette planète
dure quoi elle est due d'abord
premièrement au fait qu'on se refuse à
une politique de la ville sérieuse nous
avons pourtant un ministre sur ce sujet
qui est particulièrement compétent qui a
très bien géré l'histoire de Clichy il y
a quelques années
nous trouvons il y avait il y avait un
projet
Borlo bon alors moi je ne suis pas
suffisamment sociologue pour savoir si
c'est ce projet était enfin de la vie de
Charles spécialiste il était pas mal bon
on l'a complètement écarté et il y a pas
de véritable politique de la ville mon
premier point deuxièmement
en cette confrontation on a supprimé la
police de la police de proximité qui
était une très bonne idée qui marchait
bien on l'a supprimé on a dit les
policiers sont pas là pour jouer avec au
foot c'est le popo de Sarkozy et et là
on a créé une situation de tension avec
par exemple les c'est vérifications
d'identité ou faciès on a un défenseur
des droits qui est une institution de la
République maintenant bon c'est pas
forcément
tout bon avant clair et don il y a eu
tout bon qui dit tenait les mêmes propos
et actuellement sur l'île au dernier
rapport elle attire l'attention sur les
contrôles d'identité sur la façon dont
ça se passe dans sur les rapports qui
sont les rapports de la police avec
cette jeunesse et on sent dans son
rapport tout ce qu'elle craint d'une
éruption donc la mèche était
pratiquement allumée et ça je crois
qu'il y a longtemps que ça doit être bon
nous sommes un certain nombre et le
livre droit de l'homme et autres a
essayé de trouver des solutions car le
problème est effectivement de réussir à
réconcilier et comment comment
réconcilier aujourd'hui cette genèse des
quartiers c'est un plan essentiel à mon
avis ça devrait être principal souci de
l'État actuellement pratiquement le
principal et là le le projet Bordeaux je
crois 50 milliards moi j'en sais rien je
suis pas en économiste etc mais je dis
qu'il fallait faire quelque chose et
quelque chose qui nécessite
effectivement un effort de la Nation
pour se réconcilier avec cette jeunesse
qui est australisée et qui est une
jeunesse dans une situation
particulièrement difficile
autour d'Elizabeth borne est-ce que vous
en attendez quelque chose
est-ce que comme sur d'autres sujets les
violences et les meutes vont pousser à
ce que enfin une sorte quelque chose
autrement que des paroles lénifiantes
je l'espère je peux pas faire autrement
que de l'espérer je pense que cette
question vous attendez comme mesure
je pense qu'il faut repenser ça alors il
y a beaucoup d'autres mesures en
particulier sur n'ont pas les
instructions mais la formation de la
police il y a quelque chose d'essentiel
mais il y a pas que cela bien entendu il
y a des mesures économiques des mesures
sociales des mesures financières le bon
je ne sais pas je ne suis pas un homme
politique je suis seulement quelqu'un
qui qui essaye de de montrer les dérives
en matière de liberté et là cette
fracture sociale quand je pense que que
Jacques Chirac faisait campagne sur la
fracture sociale en 1804 19 95 quand il
a été élu et cette fracture sociale a
pris des proportions que nous voyons
tous les jours actuellement tous les
jours et voilà que c'est les meute qui
va peut-être peut-être résoudre la
question mais pour l'instant il faut
résoudre l'émeutes et c'est pas facile
alors justement pour résoudre est-ce que
ça va dépendre vous le rappeliez il y a
40000 policiers gendarmes qui sont
mobilisés est-ce que la résolution de
cette elle va dépendre de la stratégie
du maintien de l'ordre
je crois que la stratégie du maintien de
l'ordre est en cause
est-ce que il faut aller jusqu'à
déclencher l'état d'urgence c'est ce que
demande la droite
qui date de 1955 qui a été utilisé dans
un certain nombre de circonstances je ne
crois pas moi que l'état d'urgence
résoudre des problèmes ce n'est pas en
suspendant et alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pour l'état d'urgence c'est le mois de
circonstances l'état d'urgence toujours
et donc on va restreindre un certain
nombre de liberté pour que ce pour mur
est primé
alors est-ce que pour mieux que se
garantir du terrorisme ça a été utile
peut-être mais mais j'en sais rien mais
ce cas de grave c'est que l'état
d'urgence pervertit notre système de
droit et qu'après ces mesures
d'exception deviennent les mesures
générales donc l'état d'urgence c'est
une situation dont je ne suis pas
certain
parce que vous craignez ça entraîne des
restrictions de liberté si vous voulez
par exemple quand l'état d'urgence
autorise facilite les perquisitions de
nuit etc après c'est la loi elle-même
qui s'aligne sur l'état d'urgence
tellement les forces de maintien de
l'ordre considèrent que ces pratiques
et après on fait pas retour en arrière
on fait glisser on supprime la tête
d'urgence mais avant on fait glisser la
mesure de l'état d'urgence dans la loi
donc je crois il faut faire très
attention à ne pas déséquilibrer notre
système de protection de liberté qui est
déjà sérieusement atteint on va revenir
sur ce qui s'est passé précisément mardi
matin vous l'avez dit du coup il y a une
vidéo qui montre ce qui s'est passé même
si évidemment l'enquête est toujours en
cours mais l'avocat du policier assure
que le policier a tiré dans le cadre de
la loi est-ce que de ce que vous avez vu
une d'ivresse
du policier il fait son métier il fait
son métier il fait sa fonction il défend
et il a vraiment le droit de défendre et
même je crois que c'est cet homme a
besoin d'être défendu c'est moins qu'on
puisse dire mais le pour le reste les
images que nous avons vu sont des images
qui sont terrifiantes c'est-à-dire que
bon il faudra d'autres interprétations
balistiques d'autres bons mais en fait
la version des faits que nous avons
c'est quand même que le coup de feu est
parti à bout portant de la vitre gauche
directement dans le sait maintenant par
la première expertise
du corps de la victime par le bras
traversant la poitrine donc il a été
atteint sur le côté tirait à bout
portant là il y a quelque chose alors il
y a le son il y a un certain nombre de
gens qui disent que les propos ont été
venus moi je le dis franchement
j'ai pas réussi à percevoir le son bon
j'ai écouté j'y arrive pas des experts
vont y arriver c'est à dire que les
propos sont certainement décryptés et ça
c'était vous avez vu de la manière dont
le policier tenait en joue ce jeune de
la manière dont il se positionner sur la
voiture est-ce que ça correspond au
cadre d'intervention réglementaire de
police
étant notre loi est perverse l'article
435-1 l'article 435 1 c'est une loi de
2017 je voudrais rappeler dans deux mots
comment ça s'est passé vous savez il y a
eu des agressions d'une violence
scandaleuse épouvantable notamment à
Viry-Châtillon où les policiers ont été
brûlés etc il y a eu une réaction très
vive très corporatiste de la police mais
compréhensible avec des manifestations
des manifestations interdites les
policiers faisant une manifestation
interdite avec certains qui avaient des
masques sur la tête c'était
extraordinaire bon là-dessus l'État le
gouvernement Cazeneuve a pas dit il faut
qu'on fasse quelque chose et ils ont dit
voilà faire une loi qui va faciliter qui
va permettre de mieux caractériser les
conditions sur lesquelles on peut tirer
en cas de refus d'obtempérer loi mal
foutue incompréhensible la première vue
mais quand même qui prévoit dans son
quatrièmement la possibilité de tirer
lorsque simplement les personnes sont
susceptibles par la suite de porter
atteinte etc on va lire juste pour que
les gens comprennent bien c'est dans les
occupants sont susceptibles de perpétrer
dans leur fuite des atteintes à leur vie
ou à leur intégrité physique ou à celle
d'autrui pour vous on n'était pas dans
ce cadre ben écoutez le problème c'est
que nous disions nous essayons à ce
moment-là d'interpréter le mot
susceptible d'interpréter les éléments
qu'on a pour eux et là il y a eu une
directive de la police nationale qui est
arrivée disant mais non ça va doit
renforcer votre efficacité et surtout
vous donner une sécurité juridique
c'est-à-dire vous pouvez y aller vous
vous le risquez moi vous risquez moins
et donc à ce moment-là l'ensemble des
policiers s'est senti un peu peu
désinhiber c'est-à-dire que là ils
avaient quand même la crainte de ne pas
réussir à prouver la légitime défense
qui est tout à fait normal personne ne
critique le fait qu'un policier dans la
vie est menacé sauf sa vie mais pour le
reste à partir de cette circonstance et
vous savez des sociologues n'ont établi
dans l'année suivante il y a eu 40 % de
choses et cette situation fait qu'en
France il y a eu l'année dernière en
2022 13 morts et qu'en Allemagne dans
les mêmes circonstances il y en a eu un
et encore ces circonstances étaient très
Broger cet article c'est ce qu'on
propose la France insoumise
et peut-être qu'il faut rédiger les
choses à nouveau et bien le principe de
légitime défense sur la nécessité les
principes même de la légitime défense
sur la nécessité et la proportionnalité
et même l'immédiateté me paraissent
absolument nécessaire à réaffirmer dans
la loi pour revenir sur ce que vous nous
disiez de la vidéo c'est vrai qu'il y a
des images et vous le disiez
on entend en tout cas on croit entendre
des propos qu'est-ce que ça changerait
du coup si ces propos avaient été
réellement tenu le seul problème c'est
de c'est de voir quelles sont les
conditions dans lesquelles ce policier
qui n'est pas un homme sur lequel il
semble qu'il y a une mauvaise
enseignement ce policier a pris un à
faire comme il y a un acte criminel dans
à ce moment-là bon ça c'est ça c'est
très important on verra comment ils se
défend on verra surtout ce que les
Expertis scientifiques le reste du
dossier va réussir à établir mais on a
besoin de justice ceci étant le temps de
la justice il s'est exprimé dans les
décisions
des deux juges d'instruction estimant
qu'il y avait des indices graves ou
concordantes déjà du domicile volontaire
et dans celle du juge de liberté et de
la détention qui est indépendante du
précédent le plaçant des tensions
provisoires ça c'est la justice
provisoire effectivement vous le
rappelez il a été mis en examen pour
remercier de ça veut dire que la justice
considère ce qui est rare ça veut dire
que la justice considère que ce n'est
il est évident que là c'est c'est c'est
comme ça si vous voulez alors bien
entendu tout ça c'est provisoire mais en
l'état des choses la justice a estimé il
a été aussi placé en détention
provisoire ce qu'il a aussi rare
judiciaire là les les je ne connais pas
le le l'ordonnance du du juge de liberté
de la détention mais
il y a dans l'article 144 qui prévoit
les conditions dans lesquelles on peut
en transformation provisoire un certain
nombre de points qui peuvent être réunis
et le juge n'a pas dû avoir beaucoup de
mal à les trouver est-ce que parce on a
un peu le sentiment qu'il est condamné
avant même d'être jugé vous vous êtes
avocat il n'a pas droit à la présomption
d'innocence
mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire la
présomption d'innocence la présomption
d'innocence il est affirmé par l'article
9 de la déclaration des lois de l'homme
simplement le premier point c'est que ça
veut dire on ne peut commettre aucune
violence aucune punition à l'égard de la
police
d'une personne qui n'a pas été déclarée
coupable la seule violence physique
qu'on peut commettre c'est de le placer
en détention provisoires il y en a pas
d'autres et ça c'est le sens de cette
loi alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire la
présomption d'innocence dites-moi quand
on parle d'un certain nombre de ces
crimes horribles je pense au crime
d'Annecy à l'histoire de Lola etc est-ce
qu'il y a la moindre hésitation y
compris des policiers qui on parle etc
est-ce qu'il y a le moindre hésitation
en ce moment-là bien entendu il est
présumé innocent bien entendu il peut
être relaxé encore mais bien entendu
l'opinion publique dans un mouvement
général enfin chaque fois crime
abominable nous savons bien que
l'opinion publique estime que la
personne est réellement coupable bon ça
veut pas dire qu'elle sera condamnée ça
veut pas dire qu'elle les coupables
forcément ça veut dire simplement quand
l'état actuel des indices retenus qui ne
sont pas encore tout à fait l'épreuves
mais les indices graves ou concordants
c'est beaucoup et en l'état des indices
retenus on estime que cette personne est
en cause voilà et pour le reste on ne
peut pas empêcher l'opinion publique
d'avoir une position peut fonctionner
sereinement avec cette pression
mais dans toutes les affaires vous
croyez que la justice
sur toutes les affaires et vous avez vu
ce qu'elle a déclenché avec ses parents
quand brusquement la France est secouait
par l'histoire d'une d'un petit enfant
qui a été violée assassiné la justice
elle est jeune pression terrible de
l'opinion les juges sont des hommes
sociétaux ils doivent se détacher de
cela pour donner une
être complètement
indépendant et et patio pour prendre des
décisions en fonction de ce qui arrive à
leur propre conviction pour l'analyse
des faits et se donner tous les moyens
techniques tous les moyens
d'investigation pour arriver à une
analyse précise des faits avant la
condamnation donc c'est vrai qu'il n'est
pas condamné mais c'est vrai que
l'émotion publique est considérable
compte tenu des informations qu'elle a
actuellement et la pression politique
aussi peut-être est-ce que ça va jouer
là aussi Emmanuel Macron a réagi dès le
lendemain on parlant d'un acte
injustifiable in exclusable et Elisabeth
borne d'une intervention manifestement
pas conforme mais est-ce que ce sont les
bons mots
publics et en fonction de ce qui était
leur propre conviction et moi qui ai le
souci toujours de la présomption
d'innocence
si j'avais été interrogé j'aurais dit ça
parce que j'étais profondément au fond
de moi-même comme chacun d'entre nous
révolter un gamin de 17 ans enfin c'est
terrible que d'une balle dans le cœur à
bout portant c'est c'est insupportable
vous avez beau réunir toutes les bons
vous êtes obligé de vous contenir pour
ne pas être convaincu totalement pour
savoir qu'il peut y avoir une relax en
réalité je pense que sur ce sujet le
président de la République et la
première ministre ont dit ce qui
correspondait à l'opinion publique en
général plus qu'elle n'empêche pas le
terme pignon je dis le terme conviction
des citoyens et ils l'ont dit ceci étant
la conviction des citoyens ne suffit pas
à condamner quelqu'un parce qu'il faut
que la justice passe
elle peut passer dans quel délai la
justice
vous savez ça c'est un problème la
surcharge de la justice il y a deux
juges d'instruction désignés est-ce que
ça suffit je sais pas je pense mais
enfin j'en sais rien et effectivement
c'est un dossier dans lequel il faudrait
que la justice aille vite je parle
j'avais pas trop vite je veux bien
entendu il faut pas il faut pas juger
tant que la vague d'émotion de révolte
de colère n'est pas passé c'est vrai
mais il y a un moment où cette colère
prend des formes plus raisonnables cette
indignation prend des formes plus
conformes à ce qu'est notre
responsabilité de citoyen mais
il est évident qu'il faut juger
rapidement faut pas laisser traîner cela
pour qu'on est très vite parce que
l'instruction est secrète en principe
d'ailleurs il y aura des fuites toujours
il y aura déjà quelques-unes
l'instruction est secrète
les cahiers des États généraux disaient
déjà il faudrait que la struction soit
publique vous voyez c'est donc je pense
que il faudrait des fenêtres plus
importantes sur l'instruction mais dans
ce type il faut surtout dans tout type
d'affaires il faut surtout aller vite
mais aller vite c'est quand même allons
quelques mois au moins peut-être une
année j'en sais rien mais sans ça une
affaire comme celle-là s'il n'y avait
pas la photo ou s'il n'y avait pas cette
immense émotion on serait parti pour
trois ans ou quatre ans donc je crois
qu'effectivement il faut qu'il y ait une
un souci de célérité dans ce dossier en
même temps d'objectivité absolue il faut
que l'instruction soit complète qu'on
sache exactement ce qui s'est passé à
charge et à tes charges mais il est
évident qu'il faut donner une réponse
publique et le le procès pour cela
important est-ce qu'il faut aussi donner
une réponse législative il y a plusieurs
plusieurs propositions qui sont faites
la droite réclame notamment une
proposition là pour garantir la
présomption de légitime défense pour les
forces de l'ordre je suis très heureux
très hostile à une présomption de
légitime défense la légitime défense
c'est bien mais la légitime défense ça
se prouve inéluctablement il faut
vraiment que les forces de l'or celui
qui celui qui tire doit justifier qu'il
est temps qu'il est en danger et et
qu'il n'a plus qu'un si sauver sa vie ou
celle des autres enfin c'est c'est un
fondement de notre droit c'est c'est
vous pouvez pas dire que les policiers
ont un espèce de droit général de tuer
sauf à prouver que bon non bien entendu
il est les policiers ne peut être
reconnu coupable que s'il existe des
preuves de ce qui les coupables en nous
en sommes pas encore au moment des
preuves nous sommes au moment des
indices graves je concordants mais entre
nous soit dit c'est une subtilité
juridique et nous sommes pas au moment
des preuves mais mais il faut réunir
l'épreuve évidemment ceci étant la
présomption de légitime défense qui
était d'ailleurs ce qui était proposé au
moment de la loi de 2017 qui a essayé de
s'en sortir par sa partie 435 interprété
par le directeur général de la police
qui a mis les policiers dans un espèce
d'Etat de comme ils disent de meilleure
sécurité juridique c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a libéré sans doute un certain nombre de
freins Jean-Luc Mélenchon va jusqu'à
dire que c'est un permis de tuer cette
loi oh non
cette elle a été interprétée presque
comme ça voilà mais pour vous c'est pas
le cas Bernard
au moins enlever
le quatrièmement de l'article 435 ans il
faut le changer il faut effectivement
mieux caractériser et et le principe de
légitime défense me paraît être le mieux
c'est-à-dire ne tirez que les policiers
ils ont en main un instrument de mort et
moi ce que je crois plus donc la réforme
des initiative c'est une réforme
essentielle du de la formation des
policiers quand Pierre Joxe était
ministre de l'Intérieur et il avait
ordonné d'afficher la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme dans chaque
commissariat de police mais un code de
déontologie enfin il y avait des choses
qui je crois que dans la formation des
policiers nous dit mais regardez on
pendant trois mois on les forme au
maximum des armes oui c'est très bien de
les former au maniement des armes et à
la prudence nécessaire mais en même
temps il faudrait une formation morale
une formation civique je dirais plutôt
une formation civique qui montre mais
pas suffisamment il faudrait que la
police soit convaincue les policiers
qu'ils ont une fonction sociale qui est
de garantir le respect des droits et que
ça c'est fait pour tous et que lorsque
il multiplie dans le les vérifications
d'identité de jeunes simples alors dont
ils connaissent quelquefois complètement
l'identité comme des mesures etc
écouter qu'on suive les recommandations
du Défenseur des droits c'est une
institution de la République ou alors
qu'on disait on n'a plus besoin mais
mais
ça sert à quoi alors d'avoir un
défenseur des droits
on parlait tout à l'heure des propos de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est-ce qu'il y a une
partie de la classe politique qui
souffle sur les braises aujourd'hui
écoutez oui vous savez tout le monde
sauf sur les braises on est caparées il
y a ceux qui essayent d'atténuer le sous
ce qu'elle souffre selon qu'ils sont
dans la majorité ou dans l'opposition le
seul problème c'est que la classe
politique devrait avoir une obsession
qu'elle n'a pas suffisamment c'est
comment réconcilier cette jeunesse parce
que le mouvement je le disais tout à
l'heure est spontané mais enfin ça a
lieu partout à l'aval à Poitiers dans
les plus petites villes de France dans
les villages même quelquefois c'est un
soulèvement immédiat un sentiment de
solidarité d'ailleurs
vont être de plus en plus difficile si
on ne trouve pas les moyens de rétablir
la confiance oui
qui rétablirait la confiance c'est donc
autre chose c'est que brusquement cette
jeunesse
qui est tellement tellement dans une
situation difficile qui n'a plus
d'espoir qui voit leur dire boucher
retrouvent un espoir comment faire ça
c'est le propre des gouvernements
seront-ils capables de le faire s'ils ne
le font pas je suis inquiet merci Henri
Leclerc merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin et d'être venu nous
livrer votre regard sur ce qui se passe
actuellement dans le pays merci
infiniment on va continuer à en parler
évidemment tout de suite dans le club
des territoires